hello everyone how's everybody doing I
hope you're all safe
announce yourself safe visit on Facebook
again one more time I got a skip but I
was supposed to be doing here because I
had lots of questions come in and I want
to address those questions okay first of
all I want to remind everyone we have a
conference and I don't know how this
coronavirus is gonna affect that that's
gonna be pretty interesting I don't know
we got to find out and see if they close
all the airports yeah if we keep going
like this you know okay and then the
other thing I want to remind everyone
that I've uploaded a book okay and you
can download it that's for free and it
talks about the rope hypothesis brings
you up to speed on what this channel is
about okay if you have a second language
please contact us at toca caca
hotmail.com
and you know and help us out translating
it into some other language okay so all
contributions are accepted okay Bernie
language I'm translating it into Spanish
right now still in the process probably
will won't be out until April 8th I
suspect anyways let's get on with it I
want to address a lot of the issues that
were raised questions objections
criticism comments etc okay here's the
first one the first couple were pretty
nasty one person says okay I've had it I
had my fill I'm subscribing
okay and this comes at the heels a
couple months ago Franco a woman said
boycott bill so from now on it's my new
name i boycott bill okay so now you know
okay and yeah this
the site has the knack of you know
weeding out the riffraff so if what you
do is any of the following that you see
there if you do observations or you
bring those subjects up as as defenses
or attacks or as a defense of quantum
mechanics or mathematical physics or
your an interpretation of science you
bring any of these up well you're in the
wrong sight what you're doing is
religion yeah and that includes
observations experiments predictions any
mathematics whether they use equations
calculations you do measurements or you
bring measurements like important
particles especially you know we attack
particles anyone bringing the ether
which is a synonym of particles a lot of
people are not who are ether is are not
aware of that
waves we have no use for waves waves is
a concept you don't move concepts around
in physics no evidence of proof that's
for convincing the jury we don't try to
convince we try to explain if you use
any of those words mass field charge
time force especially that one at the
end called energy you know any of those
belong to religion none of those belong
to science if you talk about Pope Arian
Foster fication you bring in space-time
black holes dark matter if you move
concepts around and if you do
descriptions rather than explanations
well then you're in the wrong site okay
this is what we do here we do science
what is right science rational
explanations you see but into physics
and philosophy here we do physics and
the golden principle of physics is that
it requires an object you cannot do
physics without an object what is an
object that which has shape and that's
the first word that any person has to
define when he does physics he has to
know what an object is because you can't
do physics without an object and I like
to say that the scientific definition of
the word object destroys all religions
okay so why because people have to
choose whether they're going to move
objects or concepts and is space-time an
object well if it has shape you better
be able to draw it if you can't draw it
then you got a problem because then it's
not an object and your whole theory goes
down the drain your whole explanation
your physical interpretation okay here's
another gentleman he reserves some
choice words free I won't mention a lot
of the things that he said but he said
your wordplay is BS produced the kala
graphic Frank a fractal nature with
ropes produce something practical uh-huh
well this job you see is divorced from
physics and from science he doesn't know
what physics or science is now sorry in
science we do not use just undefined
words we do not play around with
concepts especially we have to define
our terms and if we're gonna do if we're
gonna claim that something as an object
we better be able to draw it and if we
on the other hand introduce a concept
that makes or breaks our theory you had
better define it okay and fractals know
mathematics is not a part of science
sorry
science is about explaining and math is
about describing math can only describe
produce something practical
none technology has nothing to do with
science again you know science is about
explaining and technology is about
developing gadgets through trial and
error so we do not we do not do math we
do not do technology not in science we
do not do experiments we explain them
that's part lab tech the boy the Gopher
he does the experiment the scientists
the guy who explains what happened okay
so there's a difference between doing
and explaining
so we don't do experiments in science
you can do all the experiments you want
in your basement right dark basement
when you come to the conference we want
you to explain you know if you did
gravity if you do magnetism we want you
to explain the mechanism that's what we
want to hear you know or see okay uh one
gentleman put in there and he says light
travels me waiting this year says light
travels longitudinally and appears
transverse only when it encounters
matter it's a ray it's a line
no no such object as ray no such object
as line not in physics okay so and also
no such object as a beam just in case
right physics demands objects you can't
do physics without an object that object
is that which has shape ray line and
beam are concepts line the real line you
know that one of geometry is a physical
object but it's a two-dimensional
elongated square or rectangle right
that's what a line is for example the
line that comes right after is the the
word object there at the bottom that's a
line why because it's two-dimensional
and has width and height okay two
dimensions if that's what you talk about
a line well I don't know what that has
to do is light or how the how you can
simulate light with that light if that's
not the line you were talking about you
were talking maybe about it night inner
Airy maybe or maybe you were talking
about our thinking about trajectory you
know and and you put a liner to
represent it pictorially well we don't
care about that that's your you're using
objects to represent concepts you're
using the dot to represent location
you're using the heart to represent love
that's what you're doing okay so keep in
mind what the what the context is in all
this right you get you have to look at
the context okay here's another
gentleman and he said
said the end in the aim of all
scientists is description the simplest
possible description of the given
observed of nature merely the relation
of actual to actual is valuable and this
is exhausted by description the demand
for description of the actual stands in
certain opposition to the demand for
explanation and he apparently brings
this quote from Ernst math ma who was a
primarily a 19th century researcher okay
and it turns out that yeah I've always
put this comment from Donald seminar
he's a professor emeritus at University
and he says that science doesn't explain
science describes okay now whether he
understood what he said there I don't
know but the point is that the reason
all these people talk about description
is because that's all that math can do
math can only describe an equation is
only a description there's no
explanation you can't say that you know
when you put an equation e equals
mc-squared for example or force equal
mass times acceleration or any any
equation you have not explained anything
all you've done is described some kind
of motion there okay that's what you've
done and so no math of course it was a
predictable right in retrospect if you
were in the 17th century and you had
these new researchers people like
Galileo and Newton come up kind of come
on board you know they took a tangent
and took science so-called science
natural philosophy who as it was called
they took it in a separate path they
just kept developing along mathematical
and experimental lines and they forget
about explanations and today we have
mathematics developed to ridiculous
levels the equations that we don't even
need and we have no explanation no
rational explanations for how this
universe works we don't know
in other words from from the
universities right we have no idea how a
magnet attracts another we have no idea
you know what gravity is how light works
how it does it's magic and all the
explanations you'll find out there are
all irrational completely irrational
primarily because they're in the
business of moving concepts okay that's
why and yeah here you have it this is
the difference between an explanation
and a description explanation that is
the causes and reasons in the case of
philosophy but the causes in the case of
physics and it's a mechanism okay you're
trying to explain a mechanism you're
giving a physical interpretation of some
especially invisible phenomena
some something you observed or did not
observe because you can't observe the
mechanism of light you cannot observe
the mediator of light or of gravity or
magnetism and so you have to explain how
that mechanism works that's what science
is about that's what physic as it
relates to physics right that's what
it's about
what is it the scripture is just a
listing of properties of an object so we
don't just list and say oh you know a
table has four legs and one top right
one surface is is that I did science
because of that or you know I let go of
the pen ten times repeatable experiment
right and it always falls to the floor
and so I go to the conference and I say
yes I performed an experiment it's
repeatable you can all repeat it in your
own dark basements and what I did was
let go of the pen and it fell to the
floor at 9.8 meters per second squared
measure exactly that science you let go
of a pen ten times and and you measured
you bring a calculation and that science
know the science is trying to tell me
how it is that that pen fell to the
floor that's that's where physics
vibrates okay but telling me that you
described something because you did it
ten times or a thousand gives us no
insight into how this universe works
that's why that's not science and
especially this this gentleman continues
he says the father said that that
science is about descriptions or put
that comment from brandsmart right he
says also the most prolific case of
movement in the universe is movement
under gravity okay and in that there is
no contact between objects maybe okay
when observing the universe is apparent
that objects move without contact with
objects oh is it
example magnetism electromagnetism
static electricity gravity yeah what
this gentleman is proposing is that we
do physics without objects that's
essentially his attack is his angle and
he says we don't need objects because I
don't see any objects when I said when I
do gravity or when I do magnetism I
don't see any objects and so what's this
nonsense about bringing objects in to
fill in the blanks of invisible
phenomena right yeah if you don't put an
object there you don't put an object
between the floor and the pen when you
let go of a pen and it falls to the
floor then you're explaining with
spirits you're using black magic
you're saying that the pen fell to the
floor and there was nothing in contact
with a pen with a skin of the pen and
yeah 90% of the people in the world are
religious including all the mathematical
physicists because they do explanations
with concepts you know name no problem
moving concepts around that's that's
even worse than traditional religions
that put spirits and angels and God in
there you know I can at least imagine an
angel but I cannot imagine four
dimensional space-time so so we have an
issue where these people are doing
so-called physics with non objects and
they call it doing physics no you're
doing religion that's what you're doing
and I'm sorry it offends your religion
but yeah we need a meaning
we need a physical mediator the reason
you can't see or touch that mediator
like gravity or magnetism is because
that's not the definition of the word
object and again that's why it's so
important to define the word object and
that's why the word object destroys all
religions you have to define object and
when you define object that's that which
has shape there is no provision for SI
or for touch or for any other of the
senses so you can't just go in and say
well I can't touch the mediator of
gravity I can't see it yeah because
that's not the definition of an object
the meat or of a mediator which is a
synonym no the mediator has only one
criteria and that's shape not see not
touch and that's why you can't see your
touch because you have to begin by
defining what an object is see if you
define it as si touch we got a problem
and we've covered that nauseam in the
past okay okay one other gentleman he
asked what is vacuum what is vacuuming
well first of all it's not a what okay
that's the first thing we have to get
clear up it's not a what what is vacuum
okay vacuum is a synonym of the word
nothing that's what it is nothing in
back you mean exactly the same thing in
physics not in ordinary speeds not in
mathematical physics I'm talking about
rational physics thank you no simply
another word for nothing and then space
is another synonym of these two words
thank you nothing in space mean exactly
exactly the same thing they stand for
that which doesn't have shape that's
what nothing is something is that which
has shape and they are both antonyms
nothing in something now we can use
these definitions scientifically
consistently rationally right the whole
works and anyone who disagrees with this
or has a different version okay all you
got to do is just you find the words and
we're done that's how easy it is so you
want to know what vacuum is defined it
and then we'll know what it is what is
vacuum to you okay you've got my
definitions there now you have something
to compare against at least okay because
now you get a sign
definition in front of you okay
another gentleman he put comment quite a
few comments in fact Bill's own drowning
of the electromagnetic spectrum and his
own statement he put a yes the reference
there shows that the that color is a
function of wavelength we both agree no
we don't I agree but you don't and here
let me show you how he disagreed this is
what he put a couple weeks before he
says bill things that when light goes
through a dense medium we should see a
change in color we do not please look at
the reference below it shows speed
slowing down and no change in color okay
so he was saying that you have like
going through medium and it doesn't
change color and this is when you go to
that site and look up the reference
there this which again and he's saying
that it doesn't change color the little
piece of light that folk and he thinks
all these are folks that are being
filmed and so one photon hits that blob
there okay and he says he it doesn't
change color because he thinks this is
for real okay and he of course he's
never gonna admit that he was wrong he
thought that this was the real thing
that the bozos that were ever I think
there was a Fermilab perhaps I don't
know where they did this now that they
film this and that they uploaded the
film no no this is done in Hollywood
this is cartoon okay just to make sure
that you understand this is nonsense
what you're seeing there okay it's a
simulation of what they did so no we do
not agree I agree but you don't that
light does change color when it goes
through a denser medium and and it
should be so because first of all
according to the Rope model at least
right you exchanged wavelength for
frequency okay in other words you have
the link length there's no little rope
and you can see that you know if you one
torque it you get longer link links and
fewer links and what do you torque it
you get the opposite you get more links
and each one is shorter okay so that's a
standard it's the wave equation
that's why the wave equation of light
right it can only be simulated with a
rope and this guy was saying that light
does not change when it goes through a
denser medium and you put that reference
there for that video
well yeah light does change and you
don't need to go to that video you can
just stop shining light through a prism
and you'll see that the colors out of
white light you introduce white light
and it breaks out into the rainbow
colors later on so yeah
prism does break up light into different
colors and so to say that the same color
remains through the prism I don't know
and and of course what changes is the
wavelength and that's what everybody in
his religion not in mine his religion
says that it's the wavelength that
shrinks as the beam of light hits for
example glass so it goes from air to
glass it hits a denser medium and now
what Shrunk is the wavelength and yeah
if the wavelength shrinks then according
to this spectrum and I show that the
other day here's the spectrum okay goody
does a spectrum light have better
changed colors because wavelength
changed okay and we're in agreement with
a spectrum we're saying that you know
when the links become shorter you know
you're gonna chant have a different
color that's the one on the bottom there
okay that's the Rope model of the
spectrum so we had were consistent with
that
what's that consistent we'll find out in
a minute is quantum mechanics why no
mechanics has a big trouble with a
spectrum and it's not consistent with a
spectrum okay and here we'll see it in a
minute but anyways this is this is what
essentially these people are saying most
people out there okay they're they're
different opinions but this is the main
one that quantum supports and that's
that when I've been saying for the last
couple times that you have a long
wavelength of light come in it hit it
hits glass which is that blue part in
there the wavelength shrinks in the
direction
of travel it becomes shorter and
therefore color should change inside the
glass and then when it comes out the
wavelength goes back to the same
wavelength right the same length as it
came in okay so this this is this is the
standard explanation that quantum
mechanics gives okay but this four fella
insists and he says no no look that's
not the case there's there's a different
explanation for this okay let's see what
what's the explanation so he repeats
most people willing to accept that
passing through glass would slow down
the light okay but they were puzzled
about he's quoting by the way what a
fella from Fermilab is saying so he's
just quoting that okay but they were
very puzzled about light speaking up
when it left the class yeah good
question
why does light go back to the same
frequency and wavelength as it came in
what change in between okay because now
you get explain why light goes back to
little C to 300,000 kilometers per
second it comes in at 300,000 goes
through glass at 200,000 and now it
comes back out at 300,000 okay that's
what what we have to explain and this is
what this guy is saying okay he says
they were puzzled about light speaking
up when it left the glass okay before
light hits the glass it travels at the
speed of light in a vacuum okay because
air and vacuum are more or less the same
when it passes through the glass the
light causes the electrons to move and
generates a second wave that adds to the
light in other words there is only one
way not to go he says okay and it as you
can see we were talking about two ways
we're talking about light still moves at
the speed of light that's light okay in
a vacuum but the waves from the
electrons move at a different speed and
the combined wave moves slower than
light would if the atoms weren't there
in other words he's saying here comes
light right it's got its own wave now it
goes into the glass it shakes the
electrons the electrons create a waves
there's a vibration of a wave but
electrons
mover looks lower okay and so you have
this fast light from coming from air
slow like a slow wave from electrons and
the combined way they somehow mix okay
they somehow blend yeah and the entire
wave within the glass travel slower okay
and then when it exits since the
electrons are no longer there that wave
of electrons inside the men inside this
solid piece of glass right now when
light goes out it doesn't have that
impediment and so light return
essentially never slowed down that's
essentially what they're saying okay
they're saying Gump's fast into the
glass through the glass it goes slow
because it mixes with this other wave
that slows it down that somehow retards
it and then when it comes out the
electrons are not there to slow its
speed and continues speeding at the same
velocity or speed or whatever right
300,000 kilometers per second
essentially and air well there are too
many problems with this okay so so let's
look at them here's a list okay
this idiot idiot is a person with big
ideas so we call them idiots okay and
this idiot Don Lincoln okay who
represents Fermilab he does it on your
buck on your dime you know he from you
that is a state-supported institution
this guy works there he makes money
saying it's nonsense and so it's really
ridiculous that a guy like this would be
working in such an advanced place that's
the first thing I got to say but he
never explains the mechanism okay how to
ways physically interact in fact you
can't because a wave is not a physical
entity so they users stand in this joker
this wave word they put it in their cell
the waves interact well you know what is
a way to begin with but let's continue
idiot Lincoln Lincoln justifies the
return of light to its normal speed when
it exits the glass under on the fact
that there are no more electron waves to
slow it down but it turns out that air
also has electrons and
from Wales so it's not like here is not
made out of atoms is that what he's
suggesting I mean if he said it goes
back to vacuum we would accept it but he
it's going into air so it does go back
into where there are atoms and where
there are electrons okay just keep that
in mind but that light should go back to
white when it exits the prism and not
have rainbow colors see because if light
enters at a given speed at 300,000 it
hits the piece of glass it travels
200,000 kilometers per second throw the
glass when it goes back out to 300,000
then we should not get a rainbow
we should get white light just like it
came in okay that's that's another issue
idiot Donald Lincoln of Fermilab
explains and illustrates that slowing
down of light is due to amplitude and in
the religion of quantum mechanics holds
that amplitude has no effect on speed in
fact that's one of the few things that
are right about because there is no
provision for there's no provision for
amplitude in in the speed of light or
for that matter than anyway okay but
here it is let's let's show that this is
the case okay this is the gentleman on
lincoln Fermilab and you know the
important thing here is that one of the
things you should note is that he's got
all this all these equations in the
background you know he comes in there
with this board all full of equations
throwing authority at you immediately
the first thing he does even before he
speaking began speaking right so he's
got all this stuff in the background and
he talks in front unfortunately I don't
have you know equations behind me okay I
have only bottles of rum and and beer
and so he says in this video why does
light slow down in water and he's got
almost five hundred sixty thousand views
twenty five thousand people who who
voted his video that tells you how many
[ __ ] individuals there are I mean
you know these people listen to this
fella and AM no clue what he said and so
let's find out what he said let's find
out if it if he deserves his job okay or
she should be
latrines you know at the bus stop with a
toothbrush because maybe that's the only
job this guy deserves okay the first
problem is you know he starts by showing
away so what is the wave according to
Fermilab now this is a world-class
institution okay this is an accelerator
in Chicago right and here it is this is
the famous wave okay look at that what
is that a string is that a little cord
maybe a chain I don't know and he talks
about wavelength of this this when he
calls a standing wave and what is a
bunch of vectors that's what it is
they're gonna be moving numbers
mathematicians you know wave numbers and
they call them vectors and they call
this a wave
so what's misleading about this picture
already is that he's using this this
notion of wave and there is no such
thing as a wave so he's gonna talk about
waves he's gonna use this abstraction
and he's gonna use it as a real entity
when in fact the wave the so-called wave
Maxwell's wave it's just an abstraction
it's a number he's got all this wave of
numbers that's what he's got that's what
he's waving just be aware of that okay
his wave is no good let's see how about
his atom maybe his atom is a lot better
okay I always wanted to know what had
him looks like and who else but firm you
left and tell me what an atom looks like
okay here it is looks like it's
Rutherford and Neil's Bohr's planetary
model they have these beads moving along
the wires I guess that's what it is
right so that's their atom that's the
famous scientific atom so we've got away
which is a little strange moving up and
down and just just to rub it in just let
me show you this one more time the only
reason you can produce a standing wave
is because it's got to be tied at both
ends if you're holding one end of that
string the other end had better be tied
at the other end otherwise you cannot
produce a standing wave
always always when they imitate the
standing wave they tied the other end
somewhere or have someone hold it it's
tight at some place because if you know
it's gotta be held in order to do this
right but what happens if I they go well
I can't produce a standing wave believe
me you know but you can try it in your
own basement see if you can produce a
standing wave without holding the other
end and then even even if you hold the
other end why would it go so neatly why
would it be so perfectly even
you know the sine wave that you always
see why would it be so perfectly even
I tell you to film your own your own
standing wave just tie a string or
whatever you want to the wall right or
to a post and shake it up and down and
then film it from the side see if you
produce very perfect you know waves
calculations impossible so they already
fail before starting and as far as the
atom is concerned like I said the other
day this is what they have to do they
have to tell me what the other one holds
the electron to the proton if they're
going to treat the electron is a little
bead if the electron is gonna go out and
shake and produce this wave of electrons
that's going to interfere with the waves
of light first thing they gotta do is
draw their atom and he got in the only
issue there is what is the brown stuff
what is that brown stuff that keeps the
electron bound to the proton that's the
only thing they have to explain yeah
it's very simple really you know all you
got to do is draw it and I don't care
about mother nature's and I want their
atom the one that you're gonna present I
need to see the mechanism that you're
gonna present and so far you know they
just move on they say oh the electron
does this and the electron does that no
no tell me what keeps the electron tied
to the proton to begin with before you
go and explain your theory okay okay so
what does Lincoln do well the downlink
of this fellow he what he does is
he's got to go in there and he's going
to talk about constructive and
destructive interference and he's got to
mix this he's gonna confuse this with
speed he's gonna talk about for those of
you who are familiar with it
you have one way if two waves are in
phase then they add up and they make the
wall shine with higher intensity and if
they're out of phase
well they cancel out and there is no
intensity you've probably heard of the
slit experiment that's what happens all
those fringes are waves which are in
phase and waves which are out of phase
like bands or bright bands and dark
bands that's what it is and that's what
this guy is going to introduce here it
is you know and this is all from his
side okay this is all from Fermilab a
world-class institution okay just so you
know okay first he's got to show that
ways that are in phase add up okay and
they says those that are out of phase
well they cancel out and you get a
straight line okay so far nothing about
speed okay you can see it again there
you know they add up okay
he's talking about amplitude really
that's what it is that's that's what he
show me there's nothing about speed
there okay let's see if it improves
anywhere okay here it is yeah this is a
in motion and again what you're gonna
see is amplitudes where they where they
cancel out and where they enhance each
other all these snowing is raising the
amplitude of the beam of the wave he say
look if they coincide the amplitude at
the bottom is higher and if they don't
coincide well then the amplitude on the
bottom you know just vanishes
essentially there is no amplitude so far
we're talking about amplitude there's
nothing about speed in that picture in
that illustration that this fellow
Lincoln from Fermilab put in there and
just in case he rubs it in one more time
and he does say it let's see if I can
get it here okay I think it's this one
got so many of these sometimes you can
see it that's the electron okay
and it has that red wave that's the wave
of the electron the blue one is the
light wave so far there's nothing about
speed in fact all he's showing is
different amplitude so he takes the
electron takes one electron ball he has
to describe this wave and the waves you
know they coincide the only difference
between the wave is not speed it's just
the amplitude that's what he's showing
and that's what he's explaining in fact
here here it is again in he goes through
this detail just explaining you know
what all these are here is he breaks him
apart okay and you can see that he's
gonna take this okay it's gonna take the
wave the light wave and he gotta take
the electron wave and what he does is
he's gonna have simply a difference in
amplitude he's saying the new wave not
has a different speed it has a different
amplitude amplitude has nothing at all
to do with speed and that's what this
bozo from Fermilab who makes billions of
bucks right on taxpayers money this is
what this guy explains in his video on
behalf of Fermilab okay so this guy
should be fired okay
he's no good he doesn't even know what
he's talking about and and here we have
some testimonies just in case okay let
me get back in here
just so you know what the official
version is out there which disagrees
with this bozo from Fermilab okay I
think you should be fired for saying
such ridiculous nonsense that amplitude
has something to do with speed fact you
can see in the equation down there
that's the wave equation of light do you
see any provision for wavelength for
amplitude all you have is frequency and
wavelength that's it there's no
provision for amplitude which is what
this bozo from quantum mechanics
Fermilab explains okay but there it says
you know you can look this up on your
own and google it on the Internet the
amplitude of a wave does not affect the
speed at which the wave travels of
course it doesn't and that's what this
for
individual from Fermilab essentially
illustrated and explained he did both
okay just in case you missed one you got
the other one and in another site says
the wavelength color and frequency of
the light do not depend on the amplitude
of course not they don't because
amplitude has to do with intensity not
with speed or with color okay and so
this fella Don Lincoln you know he
should really go to kindergarten physics
and learn the basics okay he's talking
nonsense
and of course he fools people like this
fellow who put the comments okay and you
know if you go down the e I just put one
out of the YouTube and there's one
fellow and this is his site but there's
many of these I just put this get pulled
this guy at random okay and he says he
talks about constructive and destructive
interference where you have all these
amplitudes which you know interfere with
each other it's got to do with amplitude
not with speed at all
so what this Don Lincoln explained he's
completely because you know what he's
standing that's the reality of it okay
um let me put this here got so many of
these putting them up here I showed the
other day from the Stack Exchange just
to reinforce that the official version
has to do with wavelength okay that what
squashes is the wavelength the wave
length is not as long it tranqs it in
the direction of travel that's the
official version of quantum what this
guy from Fermilab says has nothing to do
mean this this fellow who put the
comment he said that my vs. is
antiquated well you know it's in the
wikipedia as you can see it there these
guys also from the Stack Exchange so
instead of accusing me go over there and
Wikipedia and change the Wikipedia fight
with them okay don't tell me I don't
defend quantum mechanics so if you're
going to defend quantum mechanics at
least know or understand what they're
saying understand your own religion
right now you don't understand your own
religion these guys are saying when a
beam of light crosses the boundary
between two medium
it's frequency does not change its
wavelength changes its wavelength
changes this is the official version of
quantum frequency of light wave does not
change from medium to medium while the
speed of light and thus wavelength does
okay so it's wavelength that changes
according to quantum mechanics it
flattens out when it reaches in there
now if it's because of the electron
waves getting in the way we don't care
all I'm saying is what changes is the
according to quantum okay what changes
is is only the wavelength frequency
remains the same and that's how they
produce the shortening the the the
slowing down of light okay because again
the wave equation says C equals
frequency times wavelength the velocity
of your light is equal to frequency
times wavelength and what they do is
hold frequency constant and shorten the
wavelength that's how they make light go
slower that's their interpretation of
white light goes slower through glass or
through denser medium and wikipedia says
the same thing to refract them and this
can be seen as the factor by which the
speed and the wavelength of the
radiation are reduced okay so you want
to fight you fight you're fighting the
wrong line you gotta go into the
Wikipedian change it okay change the we
keep it there we'll know who's
antiquated okay whether it's you or me
okay right now it's you because what you
mentioned is one guy that mentions out
there that it's got to do with amplitude
and amplitude has nothing to do with
speed so I don't know if you're gonna
follow people from Fermilab simply
because they put a bunch of equations on
the board so how much authority in this
case a PhD and yeah and he would resent
Fermi that yeah you can throw it all
into the trash can this guy doesn't even
know who he is who his mother is
yeah so now and here we have a another
issue with that and that's the energy
okay see because when I illustrate the
other day is that you have these longer
wavelengths at the top
and shorter wavelength at the bottom and
in order for frequency to remain the
same in both those waves the one at the
top has to make up the difference with
speed that means that wavelengths which
are longer they have to travel faster in
order to catch up with shorter
wavelengths and what happens with that
what it means is that when light hits a
brick wall okay and it flattens out in
the direction of travel is shown in at
the bottom that means they travel slower
that's the explanation quantum Gibbs
okay so that's the official version and
you know what can I say we have a
problem first because you know here is I
showed the other day when my exits the
class it is going to encounter first a
bunch of atoms from air you know those
particles there that's air and so the
question is why does it flatten out
there why does it travel essentially at
the speed of that light travels in a
vacuum so you gotta explain that
I mean what's different about air from
glass that's what you gotta explain and
of course these people can't do anything
much less with the word way because wave
is not a physical object and this is the
way this Lincoln guy explains you can
see he doesn't illustrate what he's
supposed to illustrate he should be
illustrating ways what he does is he put
a little line there he does it all with
lines and you're supposed to guess what
the mechanism is and you won't he just
says it does so and and you better
believe it he just says that the wave of
light interferes with the electric field
in other words the electrons that are
what waving inside the glass and that's
what slows it down but he doesn't show
the mechanism you can't determine the
mechanism just by looking at this little
drawing that he did there with just
lines you know he's really gonna explain
it with waves I mean if he's gonna do if
he's gonna put it on YouTube at least
show the mechanism just tell me about
and say that it is so which is
essentially what he what he says okay
and and here I also Illustrated this the
other day we get back in here where I
show gave an example of the color red
and you can see what's happening
according to quantum mechanics okay it's
important to note that this is from
quantum mechanics I'm just illustrating
what they don't okay and you have the
wave equation Z equals wavelength and
frequency what they do is keep frequency
constant always they'd never vary or
change the frequency what they do is go
in there and shorten the wavelength okay
so the so weight length went from 650 to
433 nanometers inside the glass okay and
they say look the wavelength change
which means the color changes first it
has to change because the wavelength is
a function of color as a function of
wavelength that's first second they say
that changes and that's why light
travels slower because it's the wave
which is shortened so so now because
it's shortened it travels slower through
the glass and then again why does that
wave expand leaving the glass well you
can say electrons are no longer there
but that's not true either because air
is made out of atoms and electrons there
should be ways of electrons there they
should be interfering with the passage
of light but even if we concede that
then the light that should come out
should be white out of a prism and
that's not the case it comes out with
the colors of the rainbow as mr. Newton
showed 400 years ago so quantum fields
in all predictions to use that term okay
they fail all predictions of a prism
they cannot explain it and their
explanations are all [ __ ] okay and
here you can see what what they should
be predicting in other words if the
incoming white light is broken up by a
prism first you can see that we have a
rainbow inside the prism that's the
first issue and this means that
according to quantum that what changes
the wavelength the wavelength is what
changing each one of those waves okay so
red
as a different wavelength than blue or
violet at the bottom but then coming out
now there's no impediment from the
electrons right
there's no atoms there according to them
or or atoms that affect the the waves
and so why doesn't white light come out
okay we should have the same white light
coming into the prism as coming out of
the prism and that's not the case okay
what we have is is white light leaving
yeah I'm sorry the color of the rainbow
leaving the prism okay and so this file
continues with another comment on that
let me get back in here
and he says when you see when you pass
white light through a prism and an angle
you get dispersion well thank God he
admitted that because he the other day
he said the color remains the same and
if there's this person hopefully the
colors change inside the prism okay
that's why when they come out you see
all these rainbow colors I mean if
nothing changes then there should be
always white light everywhere you
through the prism and also you know
outside the prism white light separating
into its individual colors bill please
explain how light stays the same color
once it leaves the dense material okay
I'll explain it according to Bill once
the ropes leave the dust medium the Rope
links should get shorter where he got
this this guy put what's the put words
in my mouth
no I don't say that okay this is his
tiny brain that came up with us and
obviously he doesn't have the
qualifications to to analyze the
situation especially if he invokes the
people in in Fermilab right so any
longer wavelength light red for example
right should be converted to white or
blue make no moves and makes no sense
according to bill's own model well no as
a according to his interpretation of my
model okay that's fine now what's wrong
with this
this is the answer I give them first the
electromagnetic rope leaving a prism
does not get shorter and it doesn't
leave electromagnetic ropes extending
from an atom at the edge of the prism
relays okay
the link length imparted by the
frequency of the pumping atom and as
always I'd like to illustrate so that
there is no no no misinterpretation okay
here it is if you have eyes this is what
you should see under the rope model
which is completely in concordance with
what we see come in prison when we play
around with prisms I drew a white ball
on the left-hand side because it's not
so important we're just saying white
light comes in there okay and so I
didn't have it pumping like in the case
of red yellow and violet but you can see
that the red yellow and violet are
pumping the atoms are doing their
quantum jump right at the edge of the
prism but you can see that the blue one
or the violet one is pumping faster than
the red one and yellow one is somewhere
in between which is in accordance with
the rainbow okay that we should see
coming out of prism so what happens you
can see that the under way on the right
the wavelengths are different the red
one has longer wavelength and the violet
one has shorter wavelength okay so
what's the difference between them well
the color has to do with wavelength so
we're consistent and you can see there
on the upper left-hand corner the wave
equation and you can see what's
happening when the rope by has more
links which is like in the case of
violet it each link is shorter and when
the legs are longer well you have fewer
links that's it that's that's what we're
seeing there and so no what you have is
an atom like the red atom it's pumping
and it's gonna pump at a certain
frequency and that's the frequency it's
gonna send to the atoms down the road in
fact every atom in the room it's gonna
send that light or that frequency to
every atom in the room which means every
atom in the room
is gonna be stimulated by this atom in
the same way yeah
so no the wave does not the the link in
other words does not shorten when it
comes out it just it's the atom which
relays the signal to the following atom
down the road that's that's that's the
mechanism so please don't put words in
my mouth make sure you when you quote
you you say that this is the way you
think not the way we think that normal
people think this is the version that
quantum essentially has the wavelength
flattened out in the direction of travel
through the through the prism and so you
have white light coming in and you
should have white light coming out
because if quantum is correct and the
wave goes back to its normal state after
leaving the prism because there are no
atoms or electron waves holding it back
then we should see you know the wave
going back to white light and that's not
what we observe in other words here I I
have comparison here so you can see that
in this case you have the wave inside or
the waves plural inside the prism they
break up they disperse well then the if
if then when they come out they they
form a single in other words that they
no longer have an impediment like though
electron waves inside the prism then
what should come out is is white light
that's what should come out and here we
see the tuned one against the other see
if I put it up here
okay um face to face the one on the left
is what we see in actual laps and the
one on the right is the one that quantum
predicts since she is saying oh the way
the waves that go through the prism are
stopped by electron waves or by whatever
you want I don't care what they want to
put in there but when they come out
they're no longer stopped and light
returns to its original speed that's
what they say well if it returns this
original speed we should have white
light out and not
we see on the left so so quantum has a
big problem here okay because their
prediction does not come true Danny
they're saying that the wavelength
squash is inside a denser medium when it
exits the denser medium light returns to
its original speed partly because
according to them the wave never slowed
down to begin with because this guy
talks about two waves and then he says
oh but they they blend into one first he
doesn't explain the mechanism but
assuming he explained the mekinese to
has two ways because the the argument
that quantum makes is that now when the
light exits the prism it no longer has
the impediment that they had that it had
inside the prism that means that when
the light goes through the prism it
really goes always at the hood speed up
it has in a vacuum at 300,000 kilometers
per second somehow again the mechanism
is not there somehow the electron waves
slow it down and then when that
electrons wave is not present when it
come when light comes out of the prism
light continues on its merry ways at
300,000 kilometers per second so aside
from the fact that they do not explain
the mechanism inside the prism their
prediction is that white light should
come out of the prism and that's not the
case so you know quantum fails in every
respect and in what I give you some
homework go out there and look at the
speed of light going into a glass or a
prism or whatever and you'll find all
kinds of answers all from PhDs they all
they've never figured it out and they
never will because each one no no one
can explain it one way mechanism no one
can explain it with particles or waves
and so you know these go in one
direction the rope is a two wave
mechanism okay light goes both ways on a
rope torsion goes both ways both atoms
that both ends we see their signal at
the same time you're well yeah they both
receive signals constantly
okay whereas in the case of one-way
mechanisms such as particles and waves
it's just one way and you gotta wait you
know until the particle or the wave
comes through you and that creates lots
of problems especially when you're
trying to explain you know the
difference in speed through glass okay
let's see what I got here here you can
see the picture that you can see the
light already changes inside the prism
so so ya light already disperses inside
a prism okay and and when it comes out
it comes out as a rainbow so I just want
to confirm that that that's exactly the
case okay
none of this notion that white light
comes out but that's what one predicts
okay that white light should come out
then we have also like I said before we
have the issue of energy okay and here
Quantum has a big contradiction a big
contradiction because quantum says red
light has a longer wavelength yet
travels faster through the prism okay so
red light travels faster according to
quantum mechanics okay then violet light
okay and so we are a problem because it
turns out that red light has a lower
energy than violet light violet light or
ultraviolet light compared to what is it
the red light I can't remember the word
now but violet light has higher
frequency and therefore higher energy
but here the in insinuating the
opposites are saying look red light has
longer wavelength attract but it travels
faster through the prism meaning that
you would think you would think right
that what it is is that it has higher
energy so you know you keep that in mind
because I think they have another
contradiction there as well
they have just one contradiction after
another quantum has never resolved this
issue and this is a quantum issue people
want to say well this is classical now
this is a quantum issue because quantum
claims that light is a wave
photons also they use that word meaning
that is way packet they go back and
forth here they use the particle here
they use the wave what is the way well
we don't know it's just a way beam of
particles I guess so we don't know what
a wave is and they when they explain
this you know they they have these
contradictions where light shortens
because of the wavelength because
apparently the electron waves slow it
down inside the medium but then when it
comes out it comes out you know with all
these when it comes out of prism right
it comes out of in the rainbow colors
and if there's no impediments you come
back out white according to their own
prediction right so here's a summary
let's go to the summary because this is
what you got to take with you they have
essentially three mechanisms I only
figured out - because I can't consider
what Fermilab does a mechanism hasn't
explained anything as bozo Don lung
Lincoln yeah what is the pinball
mechanism think oh the pinball machine
you know the little ball goes back and
forth just hitting all these atoms in
this case right and light bounces off
atoms okay and therefore travels a
longer path because it's zigzags okay so
if light were to travel straight it
travels at 300,000 kilometers per second
well I can still travel at 300,000
kilometers per second but if it goes
back and forth in a zigzag it travels a
longer path and therefore it goes slower
then then the one that goes straight
that's essentially the argument of the
pinball mechanism well quantum has
rejected that because obviously it's
easy to debunk you know one of them is
that you know the main one is that light
would go in every direction of that
where the case in other words you would
not have focused light like you know
when you come out of a prism you can see
each one of the colors in a straight
line going directly in front of it that
would not be the case you would have
this diffused light all over the place
in every direction so so they they got
rid of the pinball mech enough there
that's not the solution that Navy came
up with the absorption mechanism because
that is what quantum says then you know
they then they throw the sidelights in
well no that doesn't happen but this is
the way they explain other phenomena
they say that every atom absorbs light
so if you send light to an atom the atom
will absorb that light and re-emit it
that's that's what quantum says that is
quantum mechanics and the absorption
mechanism doesn't work for them when it
comes to glass or a prism okay says atom
absorbs the photon or wave and re-emits
it but then light again with scatter it
would disperse radially in every
direction and so you know they know they
can't explain with the absorption
mechanism and then you have this idiotic
Fermilab mechanism where amplitude is
related supposedly related to to the
slowdown of light what this guy Lincoln
explained is amplitude and amplitude has
nothing to do with speed and don't take
my word for it go to the site go to this
look it up what is it the light speed in
water by Fermilab and you'll find it and
you'll find this guy giving us both of
presentation where he essentially
explains amplitude and amplitude has
nothing to do with speed so no all three
mechanisms fail for quantum mechanics
quantum mechanics does not have an
explanation and second if you go through
the internet you'll find all the PhD is
just each one with his own opinion
that's all they have and all three
opinions are irrational and they know
they cannot explain it with with any of
them separately okay they cannot explain
it so in any other about proposals light
should travel out of the prism at the
original incoming speed in other words
light should be white that's that's the
big problem with what's proposed by
quantum mechanics and in any of the
about proposals red light should have
higher energy keep that in mind because
it travels faster than violet light
actually it's the other way around
higher frequency equals higher energy
so you decide for yourself you know if
you're gonna go with the particle or
wave version of quantum mechanics or
you're gonna know with a rational rope
model because the Rope model you can at
least understand very quickly and very
easily there's there's no mystery to it
no fancy footwork no concepts we're
saying there's on an object a physical
object which we call the electromagnetic
rope that binds any two atoms and a wave
equation is straightforward when
frequency goes up wavelength goes down
and here you have it here's the here's
the mechanism when frequency goes up the
wavelength shortens okay and when
frequency goes down you have low
frequency the wavelength in other words
the link length right gets longer it's
very straightforward
and and we don't have this problem of
coming out of the prism and and then
turning it to white light like quantum
predicts though you have the rainbow
because each atom at the edge of the
prism is pumping and it's pumping at the
frequency that comes from the atom
behind it so there's an atom behind it
gives it of a certain frequency and this
one relays that frequency to the one in
front so no like you know this guy said
that maybe the way that the rope model
predicts or proposes that the wave
shrinks after coming out of the prism
that's not the case what happens is the
atom at the edge of the prism that's
gonna send the send light out of the
prism is pumping at a given speed and
that's the frequency that it's gonna
send to the next atom down the road
which is an atom of air so we have no
problem with this at all it's quantum
that has to be it has to try to explain
what they do and it'd be nice if they
would if they would illustrate their
waves how the wave of electrons
interferes with the wave of light and
somehow slows it down at the same time
that when that wave of light no longer
has the interference of the
electron ways it goes back to normal
speed okay they have to explain that
mechanistically first and second even if
that were the case what should come out
of a prism should be white light yeah so
that's my take on that today and we'll
see you on Sunday I'll have to go with
some of the other questions having to do
with gravity so please hold your breath
until until Sunday we'll see you then
don't catch the virus by the way bye